what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here John here how it should have ended
has returned for Black Panther people
John show them that shirt ha hoo it's
definitely mine undeformed share clothes
with each other we want to give a page
in the day shower really quick to a man
named Austin Moore a couple months ago
you sent me over a bunch of lines for
your Lego Star Wars fan film that you're
working on he's put together one already
that's pretty damn good you guys should
go check it out I did many it takes sent
them over to you and I know that you're
working on a live-action one and also
your Lego one I'm getting impatient
buddy where is the short film I want to
hear this voice over a Jedi I think I
play the Jedi I don't remember the lines
very much bottom line I'm really
conceited and I really want to get this
video up so I could tell people about it
and add it on my IMDB which I haven't
had active in many years
dammit Austin you're making me upset but
we love you and thanks for being a
patreon eject
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you that soon
my name is to China
I am the looking of a condor and a black
panther you looking for my father and
the ancestor oh oh oh sorry this is the
line section the popular section is
right over there
[Music]
we are shooting at us luckily our car is
elliptic yes
now I climb out into the open to attack
you as the car disabling devices you
dummy
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on here Captain America we
are having a disagreement
what's it yeah yeah I was just coming by
to see how Bucky's cheeseless costume
was going yeah
a little busy at the moment sir well do
you need any help okay guys now is
apparently not a good time let's just
come back later
oh no you have saved my life but also
cute your brother who was a treasure to
Wakanda yes we will speak nothing of
this what about the boy we should leave
him I don't think that's a good idea
we should take him with us yeah I think
if I grew up here and I turned out a
whole lot different what do you mean
nice try to find that revolution no
cousin I did not mean it
okay I'm just plenty let's just stop
giving people the tools to better their
lives if we can build a school right
over there it will get the message in
Google we have life and get these two
[Music]
you can afford a cafe this cafe is nice
it's like nothing ever happened
yeah really quite convenient and
seemingly give up on a fixing anything
would you like sir look Jack man
something tells me you're gonna have
ivory
why is that yeah me and rejoice
[Music]
[Music]
yeah sweet diggity sweets thanks that
was really funny each of those were good
points yeah they're really good points
the Lion King one is kind of nice yeah I
mean we've all heard the Lion King joke
a little bit before but I did think
about that when the car chase scene with
a koi a when she does get out it's like
a cool moment when she throws the spear
and then a car like it slams into it
when Nakia is driving we clearly have a
bulletproof car so she doesn't need to
get out and do it and okay I could have
easily got in shot so I did think that
was a really funny point but I didn't
even think about what they said their
car disabling yeah when kill mongers
getting away with a claw because they do
establish the car disabling devices when
they first go to hunt down clawed I
didn't even think about that black
panther probably could have tracked out
and just thrown that on there these
altercations vibranium man it does
anything does anything you want I feel
like that is the biggest takeaway that
we have gotten from Black Panthers the
vibranium is just a fix-all for any of
them from like honest trailers and yes -
especially pointing that out that yeah
by brainian does fix everything and
anything when the woman to poisoning
kill monger I was like that could easily
happen - and I mean it wouldn't have
been a very satisfying ending to that
well this is the one where I'm like yeah
that would have been efficient however
that that was a seem out of character
for the for the people of Wakanda yeah
granted there is eventually a rebellion
arises
but if there was just a couple of people
were like screw this let's just kill him
even though he totally beat at all you
know yeah it is hilarious how they
handle that though with like what if
they just brought back kill monger it
wouldn't have made it wouldn't have been
bad I would have made all the different
all the difference in the world
yeah I thought that and just a little
scene that they wrote laid out here was
really charming
you mean like start a violent revolution
I'm just gonna let's use our resources
and help out I love how they bring back
kill monger in this storyline and then
kill markers though comes back as a
condo inspiration at all yeah the voice
over here was really good yeah it was
really good like he did sound like
T'Challa did just sound like a dude just
doing some African accent it sounded
like T'Challa
you know I don't really remember Michael
B Jordan voice when Captain America
showed up that made me think man Oh what
are they gonna do for infinity war when
they do the or how it should have ended
yeah crazy that's gonna be a tall order
there maybe Iron Man just like shoots
star-lord get the glove off yeah just
one quick blast that worked actually I
like thinking about the movie I am
thinking Ironman could've just easily
just blasted him away yeah star-lord was
literally doing diddly squat blast him a
little bit away while they handle the
situation yeah that was really good
should've ender there's some solid
points here of things that we've thought
about I think now it's time to put the
talks of black panther behind us move on
to some more infinity war time yeah yeah
forget about that movie and just move on
to the next movie and the next move I
feel like afterwards I feel like
discussions for movies especially the
competent ones are done after honest
trailers and how it should have ended
release their video is fun then we'll
come back in a few years and revisit it
for now we're good well if you guys
haven't seen our movie review and
spoiler review a black panther highly
recommend you guys go check those out
anyway Thank You hizzy this is a great
video you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bail check us out on the internet some
more I love every one of you
including the ones who hate us I love
ones who hate us especially their the
best live a life where you try to
satisfy haters that's how you achieve
happiness